[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Merry Christmas to all and to all a good
night
left go seems different locations audio
only playoffs are coming into focus
what's good Sims hey what's up bro I
mean I could get used to this I'm
sitting in my robe right now drinking
coffee in the kitchen
hope the echos not too bad but you're
gonna get a real life Sims experience if
you're out there listening today and I
am the only person currently in the
Bleacher Report New York office
it is quiet it is wonderful and I just
want to say also today's podcast is
presented by Yahoo daily fantasy that's
right we have a sponsor o16 today's prob
I'm gonna say it again because they're
awesome
presented by Yahoo daily fantasy but let
me say it today's podcast is presented
by Yahoo daily fantasy well done
speaking of fantasy I do not know the
results yet but the SL FL super
championships that's right the champion
of all 28 leagues were facing off this
week we're have to wait and see what
happens with Oakland Denver but I'm sure
our man meat loaf Henry is gonna
tabulate it all to figure out the
first-ever
Sims and Lefko fantasy champion excited
about that also in terms of just other
podcast stuff before we break down the
games and and I have at the end of this
the top 10 left go sprinkles from week
16 and there are good ones you're gonna
like them I want to first say big
prediction that came true Dallas Cowboys
won the NFC East
let's pat ourselves in the back oh man
we're amazing we're so smart we know
more than everybody whoo yeah however
there is something that will be settled
in week 17 Sims that will determine who
picked more division winners you or me
right Baltimore Pittsburgh if Baltimore
wins the north I think we tie if the
Steelers win the north you win the
overall division winner picker battle I
got you yeah yeah my Super Bowl hopes
took a big a big hit yesterday with with
the Steelers losing certain
yeah but your Super Bowl game that you
picked Saint Steelers awesome game I
want to give you a round of applause for
like like the matchup that you picked
was a super fun matchup to watch it was
it was that was a great game yesterday
and again showed the Saints why they're
so great their ability to play in any
style game and also came back to our one
thing we always talk about left go with
the Steelers they just always find a way
to screw up some sort of situation or do
something to shoot themselves in the
foot and a day where I know we're gonna
talk about it more in a minute but I
just did in a day where I did feel like
they were the better team on the field
yesterday I'm not saying they're better
but they were better on the field
yesterday you were better than me in the
bets I'm just gonna wrap this all up
right here Sims hit his two big seven
hundred and thirty dollar bets nailing
Baltimore plus four and a half and
Pittsburgh plus six
he made currently heading into Monday
Night Football 1510 and I am currently
down 100 heading into Monday Night
Football which means if I get Monday
Night Football right I'm gonna be even
again for the week at zero Sims you're
either gonna be down 1210 heading into
week 17 or nine ninety you have made an
epic comeback I am frightened I am
nervous
you went five and oh and guaranteed to
lose and I went to 1 and 1 and I'm not
gonna lie to you Sims I ended up
switching one of my locks to the
Steelers after cam Jordan made those
comments
I'm being serious when cam Joe when that
video came out and you and me were
standing in the studio and cam Jordan
was going oh man Ben Roethlisberger
isn't a hall-of-famer
I texted canvasser and said i'm
switching one of my locks to the
steelers because i'm confident yeah ok
that's good good for you ya know the
steelers of course said they matched up
well with the Saints but it's playoff
time and I'm just getting my bets
together I'm getting ready for the
playoffs
I'm giving 110% I'm rounding into form I
had to raise my game to another level
and it's one week at a time and I got to
do it one more week next week so I could
pull even with you
like that was that was really well done
take a look at the playoff picture right
now
Saints lockup home-field advantage which
in my mind kind of locks them up going
to the Super Bowl I know that's that's a
big statement I was really exaggerating
there but Rams and and bears can still
fight it out for that other home-field
advantage but it looks like the Rams are
gonna get or the bye at the two bears
are at the three Dallas locks up the
four seed Seattle pretty much locks up
the five seed and it's gonna come down
to Minnesota and Philadelphia to get in
the six seed right there
Minnesota plays Chicago Philadelphia
plays Washington at four o'clock that's
been flexed in the AFC the Chiefs just
have to beat the Raiders and they lock
up home field advantage with a Texans
loss and the Patriots yeah it wasn't a
pretty game beating Buffalo they're now
in the two seed brushes you know yet the
ninth straight season that they'll get a
playoff by which is insane Houston gets
the three as of right now that you have
currently Baltimore at the four Chargers
at the five and then Tennessee and Indy
will fight it out on Sunday Night
Football for the six which is awesome
television Baltimore plays Cleveland
Pittsburgh play Cincinnati Baker
Mayfield could knock the Ravens out of
the playoffs which would be really
really great and we're currently sitting
here at the Steelers not making the
playoffs and I look here at the Eagles
and the Steelers on the outside looking
in and I'm going damn both of those
teams no one would want to face right
now and they both waited way too long to
make this run gosh well I mean the
Steelers it's the I mean they were eight
and two I mean they were oh I know they
just fell apart and yeah it's amazing
what your Eagles are doing left go I'm
rooting against the Eagles hard screw
you
I really am I don't like the whole
turning on Carson Wentz and everybody
thinking it's just one guy so I don't
think that's happening I know well I
feel like it is a little bit so that's
bothered me and therefore I've become an
Eagle hater now just so you know screw
you getting back to the NFC getting back
to the NFC picture though you know it is
a maze
to just what we're gonna see this
weekend with the Bears still being able
to get the number two seed yeah and
Minnesota having to win to get in I mean
it's amazing and I wouldn't be shocked
to the Rams having to play the San
Francisco 49ers man there's nothing that
would make Kyle Shanahan and the 49ers
have more happy to spoil those dreams
and take away that first-round bye from
the RAM so yeah that really is my
question was Chicago Minnesota because
the way it currently stands of Chicago
if Minnesota wins Chicago would pretty
much play Minnesota in the wild-card
round so how do you it's it's really if
you knock them out I guess you get to
play Philadelphia but also you know and
and their division rivals there's so
many questions about how you actually go
about that game if you're Chicago yes
you're right I mean playing a team three
times in a year is never fun and yes
especially when it's a team like
Minnesota who has tremendous defensive
talent and can make you know plays on
that side of the ball that change a game
yeah it's there they're in a tough spot
but it doesn't matter they're gonna play
to win because they want to be that
number to see that'll increase their
Super Bowl chances by so much and then
of course knock the Rams down to where
then they can have the rematch with
Minnesota or maybe play your Eagles
again and have to deal with that alright
we're gonna jump into Pittsburgh New
Orleans before we do one other news a
note that happened before we did the
podcast today yeah Josh Gordon
officially stepping out not gonna play
again this season came out and said I'm
taking time away for myself to figure
out how I can battle my addictions
shortly after that it kind of came out
that there was a suspension looming but
the reactions of all the Patriots from
Belichick to Brady to Edelman from
social media to press conferences to
comments they they're all taken aside
they're all standing by them I think for
me I go right to the football
perspective which is wow this is a team
that really doesn't have their offense
clicking in a passing game perspective
and they lose their main receiving
threat
it just seems like a monster blow to a
team that really couldn't handle blows
anymore ya know it's it's a tough blow
it really is and especially I always
think about just like down the future
what does it mean and I think it games
like okay if they had to play Pittsburgh
again or if they had to go to Kansas
City and play Kansas City and all of a
sudden they have to get in the shootout
and now you don't have a Josh Gordon and
that type of a matchup that's where I
think it comes back to bite the the
Patriots in the butt but just like you
saw yesterday left go they'll find
another way to start filtering somebody
else oh there's cordarrelle Patterson
back at tailback again there's Rex
Burkhead a handful of catches you know
so they're gonna just but but none of
them have the go up and get it 50/50
ability of Josh Gordon no they do not
you're right and that's I mean in a
playoff football it's it's everything
did it I mean it is in big situations a
lot of the times it does it comes down
to matchup football and where's your
best matchup across the field and yeah
you know Rob Gronkowski is no longer the
great mismatch he once was and I you
know like we've been saying for the last
month or so you know it looked like Josh
Gordon was kind of in that that trust
tree with Tom Brady as far as you know
let me throw it up but I'm with you to
the responses from the Patriots too you
know it's it just shows you that if you
go up there and be a professional and
contribute to the team they will back
you that's the one thing and they
realized the kind of guy they were
signing up there that he had demons and
yeah it seemed like those demons kind of
crept back into his life and I mean you
saw the report yesterday too left go it
sounds like it's about I week well it's
more than marijuana - it sounds like it
was multiple drugs now so that's where
it gets scary and you don't want his
life to you know spiral out of control
so good luck yeah we'll see where it
goes it's funny because I think when
people talk about it and they don't talk
about from from football stance stance
they have to make it like this huge like
statement about humanity and all this
stuff I'm just gonna say this if if you
are addicted or you are facing mental
health issues then that's your number
one concern is you need to find a way to
be healthy for you and footballs still
just a game and I'm not even doing this
to like be like I'm holier than thou
it's like I have never been in a
situation where I didn't have control
and I fear for Josh Gordon and I hope he
can get that because like this isn't
like I people are like oh he needs to
have discipline it's to me it's if you
need time take time because it clearly
looks like you need it
and that's being a humanist more
important than being a football player
yes yes exactly right your life football
I mean you know it's such a short part
of your life I played eight years a lot
of people go well you played a long time
in the NFL and I want to be like it was
nothing it was a blink of an eye it
probably felt like a snap it does I mean
my dad played 15 years and you know yeah
okay great yeah I played 15 years but
now it's you know 25 years later after
my career and you realize it is it's
just a small part of your life and you
do have to get that you know your
personal life in order and he obviously
has some issues it's more about just
addiction it's other things that he's
taking these drugs to make him feel from
have not having to feel things and
things like that and hopefully he can
get it right all right let's get into
the games we're gonna start off with
Pittsburgh now we're on second I got to
get my waitress Charlotte oh my god I
need some more coffee can you go get it
for me well just grab the pot and then
come over here and pour it for me well
this is a lesson right here we're
getting oh yes her first coffee pour
we're getting her go ahead feel free to
keep talking enough go I'm just I don't
want to get up from my spot now you
could bring it here just grab the handle
I kinda want to hear this okay all right
so Pittsburgh New Orleans it really went
exactly as you said it would like you
really nailed it to be honest Big Bend
came out there played great stepped it
up the defense showed a lot of
athleticism I will give credit to Drew
Brees and say that he played a very good
game including some very good throws the
end for me the player the game was Alvin
Kamara whatever he wanted to do he did
it was really special
at the same point Ridley getting the
ball at a crucial time and fumbling why
was he in the game yeah the the punt
fake that they did up with four minutes
left because they thought it was a
really good play and if
you're just gonna go for it then you put
Big Ben on the field the juju fumble at
the very end of the game Pittsburgh is
one of the most frustrating teams the
NFL and it all was because of their in
doing but you could have made an
argument that they were the better team
for 60 minutes yes III can you know I
what one other thing I forgot go ahead
one of many games yesterday in which the
referees were hot garbage I I mean I
think that's probably the first thing
you have to talk about because I mean
the Joe Hayden alvin kamara pass
interference
it changed the complexity of the game
from the start yes it did that was a
horrible call I do feel like yes the
Pittsburgh Steelers kind of got the
there was too bad pass interference
cause in the first half I felt like that
really hurt their team and put them in a
bad spot so yes they got a little
unlucky with the with the refs like you
said you know again yeah you mentioned
all the mistakes that the Steelers have
made throughout the game I mean of
course the fourth the fourth down punt I
just don't understand the timing of it
okay I'm all for being like aggressive
with a fake punt every now and then that
type of play and I believed what was it
left go fourth and five maybe almost
fourth and six like that's a play you
run when it's like fourth and two or
fourth and three that was the first
thing that popped in my brain it was
just that's too far to run that play in
that situation so that's the one thing
I'll say there another aspect of the
game that I thought was crazy and you
know you just think about Pittsburgh
blowing a situation and Joe Hayden had a
tough day I don't think there's any
denying that but how about the end of
the half there we go oh okay yeah
everything's good it's 14 all and they
let them go down in 30 seconds and if
you remember they throw a check down to
Alvin Kamara they have no like 45 yards
and they let them turn it up the field
and get out of bounds I mean those are
things where I looked at and go okay so
the game was tied you got momentum you
went into the half and lost the momentum
in 30 seconds and then Pitts and then
the the Saints got the ball to start the
second half and did the old New England
thing and Stan gave out a ten point
swing because a bad situational football
again by the Pittsburgh Steelers and
some big moments
man I'm gonna give you should I save my
my left go sprinkles to give you ten at
a time or shall I throw it in here as
well well if you feel like I think if
why we're talking about the game if it's
to do a game yeah let's do it
all right here are a few of my left
ghost sprinkles I had three from this
game alone number one alvin kamara is
incredible but i'll tell you what on
that exact play you're talking about do
you remember what tony romo said as soon
as the play happened afterwards he goes
what a throw and I'm like what are you
talking about
like it we still do this with Drew Brees
sometimes where we give him credit for
like the 50 yards of running that alvin
kamara did when like sure he put it
right there but it was a 5 yard throw
like that was my first thing that I
thought when I heard I was like come on
Tony you're better than yes I hear you
yet that is something that is a little
overrated in Drew Brees game we talked
about that - oh he's so surgical look at
the greatest you know completion
percentage in the history of the sport
yes he's awesome and he made some plays
yesterday where escaped out of the
pocket or it was under pressure and made
some big-time throws but yes I get sick
of that kind of talk - left off I will
say this though for the playoff run my
favorite thing to watch with the Saints
is after every play the lick lick pad
pull by Drew Brees he has OCD like he
yes only does licks one hand licks the
other and then pulls his side pad like
his chest plate on the side every time
there's no doubt about it I know all
right man yeah there's a few other guys
that have some some weird you know
quirks I Aaron Rodgers I've been noticed
in his lately - we have to talk about
that one day the I - more sprinkles from
this game when the Saints were playing
the Big Ben was trying to do drives into
the game and the Saints were playing
like 80s rock music and I was like this
is steroids for Ben like it was like it
was like they were playing Twisted
Sister and Ben's like let's go baby I
was like change the music Ben needs this
crap I did not notice that you know I
there's other games and
I'm not in control of the controller so
they changed the sound around but that
that's hilarious yes my other left go
sprinkle is Antonio Brown goes 14 for
185 and two touchdowns if Antonio Brown
played his entire career in Indianapolis
or New Orleans he might be the greatest
receiver of all time like Antonio Brown
on that playing surface is unguardable
yes he is he's well he's got the blame
of his career where he's more quick than
fast and to get a quick guy like that on
that on that surface you're right if
they become lightning fast and he was
amazing yesterday and so was juju Smith
Schuster you know I mean it was yeah I
was where you know I know you and I
talked about that last week where we
thought the Steelers could have a day
because the Steelers o-line is so good
they could pass protect these Saints
even though their defense has been so
much better you know it doesn't matter
if you give Big Ben in that offense that
has enough schematics to get open
against anybody and he has that type of
time I thought they could gash him I'm
just a little disappointed again that
Pittsburgh didn't run the ball a little
bit more and I thought there were some
times they should have ran the ball and
you referred to the Steven Ridley who
has a fumbling history and we're gonna
give him the ball on the biggest play of
the game
you know I I don't understand that one
either Simms the Steelers at the end of
the game are giving the ball to Steven
Ridley and throwing all of their passes
to James Washington's
I know well you know : I know the James
Washington it has not been great first
year there's no doubt about that and I
always had my questions about him coming
out he's kind of a one-trick pony but
you know what I did see from the Saints
in some big moments there - they were EE
they were doubling yeah but that's fine
but where's Vance McDonald I would
rather like Donnell yeah sure yeah
but overall I thought Kamara was special
Steelers it's funny on field goals
they're either offsides or they're
blocking it which I actually think is
better than just letting a team kick a
field goal
I thought TJ watt has some really big
baller moments and it just sucks because
I think the thing that sucked is to not
have the Steelers in the playoffs and to
have the entire NFC go through the same
kind of takes away a lot of the
mysteriousness of what the playoffs
could be well I mean hey that this the
Saints it but the Saints deserved they
do deserve it exactly right that's what
I wanted the Saints deserve it through
the body of work the whole gear they've
played phenomenal football yeah they're
not playing their best ball right now
but that's again like we started we said
at the start of the year they weren't
playing their best ball then and we were
like well damn they're four and one then
they're yeah you haven't played good and
they haven't played good again here the
last four or five weeks but they win
more times than not and I do have you
know faith that they'll go away for a
week in that bye week Sean Payton's
gonna they're all really self Scout
themselves and figure out some of the
things that have not worked as of late
and he'll have a whole new dimension in
his playbook for that week one
divisional round and I really yeah the
Saints are poised I'd be shocked if they
didn't make it to the Super Bowl at this
point I'm good you know of course they
could they could be upset by a Bears
team who can maybe make it ugly but I do
think the Saints are the clear favorite
in the NFC let me give the Saints props
then take one more shot at them because
it's been a fun season of doing that my
props is after the Dallas game I said
they would run the table and then go to
the Super Bowl so you're welcome and
number two I would say another thing of
examples remember when Drew Brees got
deflected at the line and they swatted
it down laughs that was a great play it
was pajama ance goes
incredible drew Brees with the awareness
to swat the bottom going or we could
focus on the fact that he's smaller and
gets the ball swatted but okay sure
yes such a hater I wrote in my notes
when I was like left go you're an
absolute hater yes I have a problem you
have you have definitely become a hater
and Drew Brees you've crossed the line
of being able to subjectively evaluate
him yes objective objectively yes and
being very subjective yes exactly that's
the exact thank you be straight now my
English there but yet again if I saw him
though I would be so polite well he's
awesome guy he's an awesome player it's
not him that's what we got to remind you
gotta remind yourself and you got to
remind everybody else either you're not
mad at him you're mad at some of the
dumb story lines or the narrow
that gets put around him sometimes that
you feel is false and I get that part of
it I get frustrated with that as well
but he's still pretty pretty
unbelievable what he's doing at this age
all right let's go from the runner-up in
the MVP race to the actual MVP Oh
another steady shot by left ko we'll
listen I'm watching I'm watching the
Saints game and it's kamar all over the
place and then I turn on the Chiefs game
and it's like Patrick mahomes by himself
with two weapons it's incredible but
Chiefs Seahawks I I can de D my
girlfriend two of her friends are like
about two we thought they were that
something big was gonna happen their
life it didn't happen so I was watching
across a bar at Kansas City Seattle so
really what's the big Sims taken this
one as Russell Wilson continues to show
how incredibly is in primetime impact
yeah I think the big takeaway I would
take from this more than anything and
it's not really gonna change anything
from what you hear me say about either
one of these teams I mean that game went
like status quo to what I kind of
expected oh the Chiefs defense could
make a play in a big situation couldn't
get off the field got dominated in the
run game I'm really surprised by that
that's really shocking I mean that's
their issue so again the Seahawks are a
different team at home I still don't
love their defense I think they're
they're going to have issues on the road
their defense it's all going in the
right direction but there's nothing
dominant on that side of the ball yet
Bobby wagons are still the best middle
linebacker in football but I'm just
talking about you
yeah he's still amazing man I mean every
week it's just it's it's it's top-notch
folk boys having one of the best years
of his career this year but yeah I just
don't look at any one unit on their
defenses say that's a top unit in
football right now
Russell Wilson his ability to make big
throws and that run game is special to
where yet they're always gonna compete
Russell's always gonna make plays and
that's why they're dangerous and the
playoffs and their ability to run the
ball control the clock but you know then
going over to Kansas City left go it's
the same issues yeah it's two guys or
it's three guys you know I'll give Andy
Reed credit for staying a little patient
with the run game but
this is a team and I don't know if you
saw what I said on Sunday Night Football
like I just can't trust them and any
type of games like this because I don't
think their defense can make a stop to
win a football game if their I will
doesn't have a ball I don't think they
can win sorry yeah go ahead no no no you
finicky finishing your point yeah I just
if if their offense doesn't have the
ball last like we saw in the Ravens game
and things like that I don't think they
can win a football game and there is
still you know I think teams have
figured out how to play Kansas City and
you've heard me complain about this with
Kansas City a little bit already they
they just run their place they try to
dress them up pre-snap but I do think
that they're gonna have to find some
more wrinkles in their offense as is
right now and especially without Sammy
Watkins again I can't I can't
overemphasize that enough like Kansas
City is a playoff team without Sammy
Watkins but if they have Sammy Watkins
they're a Super Bowl team and that's how
big of a deal they're missing him Mike I
would if you made me reap ikh teams
right now if they got a healthy Sammy
Watkins for the playoffs I think I'd
still pick Kansas City to go to the
Super Bowl in the AFC but without that
I'm not doing that right now
maybe he'll be healthy yeah because
right now my two takeaways for those two
team yeah I'm here and everyone right
now go ooh nobody wants to play the
Seahawks [ __ ] nobody wants to play
the Seahawks in Seattle exact everyone
should be very fine playing this like
how quickly we forget that they went to
San Francisco and San Francisco move the
ball up and down at will and then they
relied up and beat them and they had two
passes to Doug Baldwin who I will say
looks healthy healthy again but that's
my first thing in the two is by Kansas
City having a home field advantage that
in essence mean that the Patriots have
home-field advantage because I believe
that the Kansas City Chiefs have so many
holes that they're either gonna get
eliminated shockingly which really isn't
shocking with Andy Reid the Chiefs and
the playoffs in the divisional round or
if the Patriots end up going there in
the championship game I think they'll be
fine because Tom Brady's going to be you
know other than other than the one or
two huge plays that Chris Jones makes
that's it
yeah that's right it's it's there there
their whole defense depends on three
people fifty fifty-five and ninety-five
and if Houston our Mandy Ford and Chris
Jones can't make a mockery of the
offensive line they can't do anything on
the defensive side of the ball there's
nothing else I look at and go oh wow and
you know it's too hard for three guys
like that at that position to ruin a
game because the other thing that has to
gets thrown in too even though you go
and go wow this is one of the better
pass rushers in football you they still
don't have quality depth behind it so
they die out at the end of games and
we've seen that the last few weeks there
there's only so many times you can go a
hundred percent rush to pass or full
speed I have a 315 pounder hanging on my
shoulder and I'm either pushing them or
trying to go around the edge on them all
game long yeah anybody out there you
tried doing that and see how you feel
late in the fourth quarter you lose some
of that explosiveness and yeah that's
where they hurt right now because at the
end of the game those guys aren't as
fresh and they can't close games out I
will say that I'm loving the offensive
system of the Seahawks in terms of the
way they've established the run and now
with the over-the-top aspects of Lockett
and Baldwin really giving them some good
levels concepts which is I'm so happy
that Russell Wilson's finally getting
the credit he deserves and also I just
Sims I don't even want to talk about it
anymore but mahomes is so the MVP it's
like not even close he's the only reason
they're here like I I think what I'm
gonna do for later this week is I
believe the MVP should be like a boxing
fight where you look at how many MVP
worthy weeks you had how many weeks
could you have been considered a
top-five MVP candidate and I'm pretty
sure at this point mahomes has been that
for like 11 and a half of the 16 weeks
and I think Brees has been that for like
nine of the 16 weeks and it's just about
consistency on the road and I'm still
going I'm still seeing this Sims oh
another big game against a playoff team
that mahomes loses and I added it up
they've the Chiefs have allowed 41
points per game in their four losses
like 41 I know so we're gonna put those
41 points on the homes and everyone
likes to bring up the few turnovers in
the Rams game he had six touchdowns in
that game he was the only reason that
they were in that position yeah also in
all four of their losses he wasn't
really on the field like right so I it's
at a point now where it really
frustrates me and I can't even have like
a sensible conversation cuz I just want
to hit people and and violence is not
the answer no it's not no I mean is that
his fault Kelvin Benjamin dropped the
ball in the end zone last yeah I mean so
yeah I'm with you I do feel like it
turned a little yesterday left go I will
say that I feel in it because I'm still
getting dumbest well yeah I just to say
just from football people when I was
watching pregame shows on TV yesterday
there was still you know one or two that
oh maybe this you know Drew Brees I'll
never have a chance to win it again
there was that talk where I wanted to be
like are you kidding me that's the
dumbest point ever but I do think that
most of the football people I saw were
just like yeah I think Patrick mahomes
has got it he's clearly the MVP and you
know again as long as booger and Whitner
at the votes I'll tell you what wit cuz
of them interceptions I think I'm gonna
have to go Drew Brees I agree with you
because he's such a good leader like
okay anyway and again you know just like
to remind everybody that what he's doing
is with the same talent Alex Smith had
on the team last year in fact it's less
because Alex Smith had Kareem hunt at
Albert Wilson all year and hey Simms
someone tweeted me last night yeah
the only stats that mahomes has over
Brees is passing yards and touchdowns
yes and in my head I went oh you mean
the two most important stats that's it
like I like that was their argument for
Brees as though like completion
percentage and interceptions and like
get the [ __ ] it's become
they all talked about for the last four
weeks how the Saints had the best
scoring defense in the NFL and now like
get out of here yeah I can't it's me
come with Patrick mahomes a little like
Aaron Rodgers where we're like oh it's
Patrick mahomes coming into town this
week we don't even say the team we just
say the player you know what I mean
like even with New England it was like
oh gosh it's Brady and Belichick and the
Patriots and you know you had a you it's
all of that encompassed and even with
the Saints I feel like it's the same way
like oh it's Sean Payton and Drew Brees
together but when it's Kansas City its
everybody turns on because they go I
wouldn't watch this young player Patrick
mahomes and to your point let go to just
to show you what guys are being asked to
do I mean mahomes has completed five
more passes and Drew Brees this year for
nine hundred more yards
so their completion he has five more
completions than drew Brees but nine
hundred more yards so that just tells
you what he's being asked to do when he
does drop back to throw yes I think it's
the hardest thing about football is
knowing what is actually out there to be
done yes and not just looking at the
results exactly right what's there to be
had yes 100%
all right let's move on to Philadelphia
Houston so my dad was at the game and I
you definitely didn't see this but there
was this thing on social media this guy
got on his skull tattooed the lii
Superbowl of the like the Eagles
Patriots right and I've always forgot my
dad sits in the section with this guy
called tat man and his entire body is
covered in just eagles tattoos right
like I went there for a pre and it's
that guy and I was like oh my god I was
wondering I said dad why does he die did
he get it said AFC an NFC and not
Philadelphia New England he goes because
he's going to tattoo his entire head
into a helmet and I was like oh my bad
continue to do your thing yeah
unbelievable
Philadelphia Houston Nick Foles magic
it's it's unbelievable the fact that
they go up 13 off
beautiful bomb - Nelson Aguilar we're
getting we're getting crossers - al shot
I haven't seen al Shan look like this
all season I'm seeing he gets hurt on a
third and ten - al Shan by Jadeveon
Clowney nade sud Feld has to come in the
game he's he throws an incomplete pass
Nate son fell came out and said he
thought there was defensive pass
interference because the crowd erupted
but it was just Nick Foles running back
onto the field on a third and ten he
completes it - Zach Ertz they overcome
incredible plays by deshaun Watson where
he's looking like Michael Vega
overcoming a deficit and and Nick Foles
drives down and they win the game I'm
talking about
fourth down completions to Darren
Sproles where he makes a few people miss
I'm talking about fourth down
completions - a touchdown in the end
zone it makes no sense to me
I have no bearing of where I am as a fan
all I know is I'm wearing a ski mask at
my house and I'm praying that this team
gets into the playoffs because I don't
understand it Chris long is getting
sacks after you called him out last week
Hester's getting sacks dude it makes no
sense to me well I mean it their honor
they found their mojo I mean I think
that's the biggest thing their backs are
against the wall and your your Eagles
team is phenomenal when their backs are
against it is it's magic you have played
two teams that you match up well with I
will say that and what was well I just
say you know again you played a team
that you know okay they're there they
let up a lot of big plays in the
secondary just like the Rams do right
and their front for you know your
offensive line was capable of handling
their front four teams yeah but our
offensive line can handle that front
four they could handle any front four no
doubt no doubt about it yes you're
exactly right added to the fact that
what's been my biggest thing I've said
about the Houston Texans they let up too
many big plays in the past game always
it's
it's every week we saw Sam Darnell torch
them last week and the Jets I mean so
that is a big issue with them they you
know you just think about your like you
said the big fourth down throw great
call by the Eagles good job by Doug
Peterson realizing what the Texas do
they throw the wheel route to Sproles
out of the backfield right yeah they
brought that they brought the tight end
across the formation the wide receiver
across the more Meishan and kind of
created a one-on-one yet created a
one-on-one where the linebacker had to
try to fight through some traffic and
get through there and yes he couldn't
get over but it is there's just too many
big plays led up in the backend by that
Houston Texas defense and yeah if foals
was phenomenal there's I mean there's no
denying that that was amazing the way
he's stood in the pocket made big throws
throughout the day I will say that when
he is in it does seem like the ball gets
spread around more and carson wentz
maybe does lock on to Zach Ertz a little
too much but again I'm even though
Earth's had like a thousand catches
yesterday yes no I know I know it but
again I Nick Foles is playing really
good I don't want to take away from that
but I do want to make sure that
everybody knows the whole team is
playing better it's not just Nick Foles
I think a place like last week yes there
was not a whole lot different there was
a few different little shot plays that I
hadn't seen them call like your deep
throat at Alshon Jeffery where the Rams
you know broke busted their coverage
there's been a few little wrinkles here
and there nothing groundbreaking till
I'm going wow I think the biggest thing
last week what I said was the run game
even yesterday at least you ran the ball
when it wasn't being successful just to
keep them honest and then you know you
flip over to your defensive side of the
ball
that was a good matchup for you guys too
because it's not a great pass protecting
all line your front four could get there
by itself it saves your secondary they
don't have to Marius thomas halfway
through the game exactly right so they
have no weapons and there that's their
big issue right left go I mean you know
you've seen me write that in my notes a
million times to the Texans their pass
offense is just not special and as you
saw in a lot of the special plays
yesterday it's just Watson making
something happen and let me find DeAndre
Hopkins and go from there and I kept you
your Eagles defense yesterday going can
we just double the only guy he wants to
throw do I mean all he wants to do is
throw DeAndre Hopkins I don't know why
teams let him get away with throwing
into him so much especially in the third
down or obvious passing situations but
yeah those are things that concern me
about the Texans that's why the AFC is
fascinating its last name
nobody ever anything it's I've never
seen it like this to where I live what
that means what that means doing let's
go to the Superbowl
I don't know I feel like it's a year
where they're not I do feel like that
but I won't I wouldn't be shocked but I
don't know why but I feel like I mean
the Pats are not set up for the Super
Bowl
all right so one thing before I have a
few left go sprinkles in this game yeah
one thing boy were the refs bad in this
game they were holy crap there was a
two-point conversion of which Nick Foles
got thrown by his facemask by Jadeveon
Clowney in front of the ref not called
later in the game Brandon Graham
roughing the passer where he didn't even
really follow them called I mean dude I
don't know if you saw the unnecessary
roughness in the Dallas Tampa Bay game
that was called on Xavier woods that was
at a crucial time of the game that was
awful yeah and look look and I wouldn't
normally do this I don't like I mean I
have done this so I would do this but
like Peter King wrote a whole thing in
his in his article today about former
referees coming out and being like it's
really bad something needs to change but
we did predict this before the season
when four of the head referees retired
right no it's it's the inconsistencies
that drive me crazy more than anything
it's how in one game you watch it and go
oh that's not defenseless receiver but
then you turn on another game or you're
in the same game and it's just a bigger
moment in the game and the same type of
play happens and now it is a penalty or
well it's just all over the place I
think that's what drives fans crazy is
at least what drives me crazy there's no
consistency within the game and there's
no consistency when you watch different
games and that's that's annoying because
if you if you felt like okay this is the
way it is for the day then you could
deal with it but it does seem a little
wishy-washy
alright so my other left go sprinkles in
this game
one deshaun Watson has a sliding problem
yes deshaun Watson for the second week
in a row on a third down runs for the
first down and then slides a yard before
it he doesn't realise that it's where
the ball is not where the feet are other
than that though I would I honestly over
Baker Mayfield over everybody I'm taken
to Shawn Watson as the best young
quarterback in the NFL other than
Patrick mahomes because Watson really is
that I would take Watson over Carson
Wentz right now even if once was fully
healthy I really would
yeah I would do I I would Watson is
special and you know yeah he takes some
bad sacks at times and yes he doesn't
throw the ball away and he does the
little things like you do I he
definitely has to learn to stop taking
hits but you have to live with him
taking some of those sacks in those
plays because of the play we saw towards
the end of the game where he broke four
tackles and then threw the ball down the
middle of the field to I can't remember
who that was but regardless yeah it's
it's special play making ability but I
was working Smith I think it might have
been you were exactly right it was it
was like his first or second catch ever
but it's the it's the it's the same
thing I worry about them what we've seen
with the Texans when they play a quality
defense they can't run the ball and it
becomes all on deshaun Watson I mean he
can't lead the team in throwing and
running in big football games like that
and that's what he did yesterday and
that's to me that's what Moore Miller
back will be good they definitely need
Lamar Miller they have to they're gonna
have to find creative ways to run the
football to left go because when what we
seen is they kind of the run game feast
on the week where they run good against
bad defenses like Cleveland exactly or
they never seem to be able to run the
ball or against the Miami Dolphins but
they never be able to seem to run the
ball and you know against playoff
quality defenses like the Eagles and
that front four and what you have there
so your egos man they're sitting pretty
the other left go sprinkle I had is for
everyone that wants to know should the
Eagles go with Carson Wentz in the
future or Nick Foles
I believe that the Eagles after this
year no matter what happens should
announce that their starting quarterback
going forward is Carson Wentz I also
believe that they should announce that
they're closing quarterback going
forward is Nick Foles they should treat
this like a pitching staff okay this is
the overall despair whoever starting
pitcher is for the Yankees I have no
idea
CC Sabathia okay sure I'll either rather
you go with Severino he's the better one
every this is the Brad Lidge to the Cole
Hamels for my 2008 Phillies I'm bringing
Nick Foles back and I'm letting Carson
Wentz play regular seasons and I'm
letting Nick Foles play post seasons
because if this is what happens when
Nick Foles comes in I saw him early of
the year it's not the same
he's my closer why can't I have a
closing quarterback and a starting
quarterback I think that's the way that
you win Super Bowls no it's not the way
you win Super Bowls fan boy they need to
they there I got to imagine that this
was gonna trade Nick Foles right now
well this is it right this is his last
year of his contract yes right so he
will go hunt him one more they have a
mutual option which is fascinating yeah
well he's gonna leave and they're gonna
let invasion compliments of me that
comes they're gonna let him leave
because they this is the type of thing
that's gonna divide the locker room or
then find you sign him and trade Carson
Wentz but I don't I don't really care
either way I'll just say this we're all
forgetting the best Eagles team I ever
saw and my in my lifetime was the one in
the first 14 weeks of the season last
year when Carson Wentz was the MVP of
football that was the best Eagles team I
ever saw yes you won the Superbowl but
you weren't as good at your best with
Nick Foles last year as you were when
Carson Wentz was at his best so I'm
sorry you're worried I know you won the
game and we're gonna have to hear this
talk constantly and I have a lot of
respect for Nick Foles certainly but my
friend Dan nailed it
you
Brendon said the worst-case scenario for
the Eagles is that Nick Foles goes into
Washington and puts up another 400 yard
three touchdown performance and
Minnesota wins and thus we don't get
into the playoffs right and we're
sitting with a huge quarterback
controversy yes the worst-case scenario
for the Eagles heading into the
offseason yeah it is I I don't know I is
it worse than you guys actually winning
and going into the playoffs and that's
because if we go to the playoffs if we
make a run like like I'm still a fan I
still want to see them like holy crap
what if this continues because then like
maybe he gets shut down in a playoff
game or god forbid he goes and wins the
Super Bowl that the best case scenarios
Nick Foles wins another Super Bowl and
then we're like okay but we're still
gonna ride with wins yeah well there's
no way there's that won't happen that
you know that's where I go I don't even
know what's best for the old guy fine
you know what fine you know what if Nick
Foles wins the Super Bowl I will gladly
discuss trading cars are you kidding me
we'll think I'll take another Super Bowl
who cares like sometimes we forget the
point is to win Super Bowls not to just
have a good quarterback for eight years
yeah no I think you're right that gets
lost a little something but Oh can't
wait to have that discussion for the
next eight months holy crap all right
but we cannot forget about Baltimore
Chargers the other game that you nailed
it was the Baltimore team that was
bigger like usually held it too right I
mean you nailed it
oh well cuz to me look I have been
questioning the Chargers all season long
and they have made me look dumb with
their comeback win against Pittsburgh
and their comeback win against Kansas
City but Baltimore was one of those
teams that matched up really well yeah
and I actually think the Chargers are a
better road team than they are hoed team
they started off slow in their last five
home games slow against Baltimore slow
against Cincinnati
they were down 10 nothing to Arizona
it's like they've they start off slow at
home and Baltimore's not a defense that
you want to do that to Melvin Gordon did
not look healthy the options for the
Chargers from the
reciever Keenan Allen looks slow because
he's not that fast right and Lamar
Jackson Gus Edwards in Kenneth Dixon
kind of got whatever they wanted but in
pure Baltimore fashion man they could
have lost that game at any moment if it
wasn't for that punch-out and fumble
return on a Antonio game yeah okay I
mean they could have lost the game they
probably I mean I know you and I were
texting they probably should have been
up like 13 nothing at the start of the
game right the other they're one of
those teams to where you look up a lot
like you know there's a few teams in
football you look up and you go holy a
little bit like the Pittsburgh Steelers
in a lot of case where you go Chicago's
like that yeah you're there kick and
this notices like yes exactly they're
kicking the [ __ ] out of this team and
they're only winning three nothing like
what's going on or if Carolina's season
exactly
so all right there's one point I want to
bring up before I just dive into the
game you know the one of the biggest
moments of the game and it fortunately
did not come back to bite Baltimore in
the ass but when Baltimore had the ball
backed up in their own end zone at the
end and they were up sixteen to ten
should have taken the safety exactly
that was a bad move I was shocked that
John Harbaugh who's usually all over
that type of stuff didn't do that that's
the bright play in that situation right
left go you take the safety you're still
up by four points but now you're gonna
be able to kick the ball off and Phillip
Rivers is gonna have to go the length of
the field to score a touchdown to beat
you instead they chose to punt it and go
oh you only have to go 45 yards to beat
us for a touchdown
so I just found that interesting that's
just something I'm pointing out for the
fans to look out for in those type of
situations because it's cool but I think
my big thing would be this from the game
I haven't seen Phillip Rivers that
confused just under duress mentally and
physically in a while my announcers
continue to bring up throughout the
entire game Eric Weddle history with
rivers and his the way he goes at the
line and then shoots back and it did
look like Phillip was having a hard time
identifying scheme yeah no doubt about
it that's what the Ravens do to you
they're scary that way you you you know
not only are they big and you know
physical and you get out there on
field and even things you saw in film
where you go oh it's open I saw them do
this against this team
it all looks easier on film until you
start to realize wow these are really
big these passing lanes aren't quite as
big as I thought they're pushing people
back into my face a lot more closer
we're gonna look are a beautiful mix of
an an inventive coordinator and enough
athletic veterans that can execute the
game plan and take it to the next level
that's right like Drew Brees in the
Saints offense is that on the offense
the Ravens defense and Suggs and Weddell
and Mosley and all those big guys and
even a guy like Carr at quarterback
who's like people forget was a top
corner for like a few years but have all
the pieces that don't just execute but
can also add wrinkles themselves yeah
exactly it's not about just execute it's
about their football acumen their
ability to know what's trying to be
accomplished their ability to disguise
things they're all on the same page you
can really tell that they all understand
each other's job that's one thing when I
watch film on the Ravens like the corner
understands exactly where the safety is
supposed to be and where the linebackers
supposed to be so that makes him better
at covering his guy because he
understands where his help is but yeah
how many times in the game right left
code they do BC Rivers drop back and he
go oh gosh you know he's under a little
pressure
there's nobody open downfield let me
throw my short guy oh gosh he's covered
let me just take the ball and hold it
and I'll get sacked right how many times
did you see little moments like that
where he thought oh I'm gonna throw it
be able to throw the ball to my safe guy
oh my gosh he's covered - what do I do
and that's like you - what you said the
Ravens are a game plan specific type
defense where you know yeah it's cover
two this week and then the next week
it's covered - again but it's a
different version of cover - that fits
how they want to defend the team they're
playing on that week and I think that's
what's impressive about them that's what
makes them dangerous in the playoffs - I
mean that D and that run game and Lamar
we're seeing is capable of making a few
big throws every game to give them a
chance so right now it's looking like
it's gonna be Chargers Ravens in the
wild-card and
I feel like is it's a it's it's harder
now for Baltimore yeah I feel like they
just played their perfect game I'm also
a firm believer that I know we haven't
had a wild-card team win the Superbowl
in eight years since Rogers did it if
there's one team that can do it because
they'd love to play on the road it's the
Chargers like I really think if they get
on the road sometimes they're more
comfortable because Phillip loves to be
in that I'm gonna ruin your dreams
mentality my question just to wrap this
game up for you is where are we with
Lamar Jackson because in the second half
he wasn't able to complete any passes I
just I just wasn't sure how much was him
how much was good charger scheme from
what you saw yeah from what I saw I mean
the Chargers pass defense it's pretty
damn good I mean their pass rush you
know they have a lot of speed in the
back end so you know uh you think you
have holes in the zone and you throw it
in there and you realize oh man that was
a lot closer than what it what I thought
it would be uh I'm still very positive
on Lamar Jackson and all the things he
brings to the table me sure his running
is special and he makes you know a
handful of special throws every game
it's not perfect I get that there are
still moments where you know he flicks
the ball or he doesn't do things
mechanically right but you know like you
saw with the big touchdown pass in the
third quarter when they were down ten to
six he answers right back and throws a
big time throw to the kid Andrews the
tight end going across the field and you
know those are the type of things that I
think we'll continue to see as he gets
comfortable you know right now you've
got to give him the benefit of the doubt
because he's being told all week like
hey we're running the ball
we're playing defense be careful it's
really hard to play quarterback like
that I really can't stress through that
enough like we've talked about that
Matthew Stafford right this year where
he's having to play that way and it's
like culture shock it's the same thing
with a guy like Lamar Jackson nobody's
told him anything his whole life because
he's always been like so gifted they're
just like go play and go win the game
and now he's being managed and he's
dropping back and seeing people open
where he might normally throw it but he
goes he can hear his coach's voice
Harbaugh in his head going it's okay to
did our defense is really good and you
know I think we have to take that into
account too but I think all is still on
the up and up with Lamar
speaking of hardball Friday night seven
o'clock press release comes out they're
working on an extension Peter King
article comes out Monday morning he
could still leave
yeah it's getting spicy and Baltimore I
love it yeah I do think you know I want
horrible to leave not because I don't
want him because I think him and Lamar
and the way they've built this team
could be really good right but Harbaugh
I feel like is like starting to realize
his Worth and is like I can start a new
somewhere if I really want to and hit
the free agency in a year where there's
not a lot of great coaching candidates
and demand a salary in the 8 to 9 to 10
range yeah well he's a phenomenal coach
you know I'm a big fan of him really and
he I think that really and this is some
League people I've talked to there's
some thought that the Ravens are signing
him but you know they're gonna sign him
back and maybe give him an extension but
also might still be willing to trade him
like a la like Jon Gruden back in the
day there was a rumor there was a rumor
two weeks ago that the Bucs might be
interested in trading for him I I
wouldn't be shocked I think the - that
there's there's two teams that I know
and one for sure like the Miami Dolphins
Steven Ross he definitely has his eye on
John Harbaugh III know that and I think
he really actually wants Jim Harbaugh
but he doesn't want to screw over his
alma mater in Michigan so he's moved on
to join the other one I'd watch out for
is the Denver Broncos I do think there's
a little something going on there where
they wouldn't mind if John Harbaugh was
available to bring him in so there's
going to be options for a hard ball he
would be yes if he's made available will
be like the Most Wanted guy in the
coaching search and it's not just John
I'm seeing articles today the Jets are
interested in Jim yes well you've heard
me say that I have hurt you only one I'm
the only one that's currently being a
part of this podcast that's heard you so
you can share some stuff yes
well you're right so
I've been telling everybody out there
and left Coke and voucher me I've been
telling let go for about the last ten
days that I know there's one team that
is not going to do anything until
they've talked to Jim Harbaugh and I
believe I finally told you what last
Thursday maybe I finally said I kind of
you you told me like you normally do
which is I'm gonna tell you something
but don't tell anybody so I so I did I
let you know but yes the Jets are that
team and I think they are looking to
make that type of splash signing with a
Jim Harbaugh maybe make him the
highest-paid coach in all of NFL maybe
the highest-paid coach in the history of
the sport
exactly deal I know to get him in here
and get the fan base behind it and
everything and I better hope it's a
four-year contract cuz yeah there's a
lot of things you got to worry about I
mean you got to worry about the GM
that's in place do you want him to deal
with Jim Harbaugh can he deal with Jim
Harbaugh is Jim Harbaugh gonna you know
go behind his back and played politics a
little bit what happened with San
Francisco with him and Trent Baalke
Balki's so there's a lot of things that
go into play when you signed Jim all
right let's go through some of the best
moments some betting and then some
sprinkles and we'll get out of here go
over the best moments of the week the
Kyle Rudolph he'll marry at the end of
the half crazy if you weren't watching
that game Detroit was dominating that
game dominating Kyle Rudolph touchdown
Minnesota runs away with it and the
playoff implications of that were crazy
right because now it put Minnesota
really back in the driver's seat but
what an awesome throw Kirk Cousins
pulled in Aaron Rodgers in Detroit
against Detroit in Detroit dare you
steal my lines left go yeah that was
pretty awesome and it was in the same
end zone right am I am I correct - the
same one that he threw it to Richard
Rodgers yeah and you know what's amazing
like the thing I look at right away is
of course I mean Kirk Cousins got it out
there ready threw it about 60 60 yards
right somewhere in there and maybe 65
ish it was before it was from a forty
force but and I think it got about five
yards in the end zone right so it's
about 61 yards - think about the thing
I've looked at more than
anything left go is raw I mean Rogers
through it sixty six or seven but the
thing I looked at more than anything was
how much higher Rogers ball went than
Kirk Cousins when you I went back and
watched the highlight cuz like people
were showing it like look it's a lot
same Rogers ball went like an extra like
twenty five feet in the air which was
unbelievable watching that back props to
the offensive coordinators we've been
giving a lot of props to the one in
Cleveland that came out of nowhere and
has been killing it Freddie kitchens
yeah and also props to sue fan ski the
two issues with the Vikings offense this
year where's Dalvin cook and why is Kyle
Rudolph no longer existent Kyle Rudolph
with a monster games to fancies got that
offense clickin yes he does I mean he
just he's at least making you defend
something where he's gonna go okay well
we got Dalvin cook and we're gonna run
and football yeah I was just gonna say
the football fan in me knows that the
Vikings are a better playoff team than
the Eagles but at the same point the
mystery of Nick Foles means the Eagles
could really compete with anybody yeah
you're exactly right and you know to the
tight end running back for like they
play hand-in-hand right I mean how do
mean how do we see Gronk get it so open
in New England all the time oh they
faked them they faked the run game and
then it's Gronk down the middle you know
that's such a big part of tight end play
as being able to run the football to put
those linebackers in a bind to go okay
you're gonna stop the run or you gonna
drop back in coverage and stop our tight
end going across the middle and I think
that's why you've seen that there yeah
the Vikings as much as we don't talk
about them they got all the pieces they
don't need anything special offensive
line that'll be an issue they certainly
will and if Stefanski can find ways just
to kind of save them here and there in
certain situations and be creative and
run game design and things like that
which you can you can find ways to slow
down that interior part of the d-line
yeah they could be dangerous because of
that defense and cousins and digs and
Thielen and cooks they can make plays to
where they can upset a team that's maybe
better than them in the playoffs other
great moments Aaron Donald is now at 19
and a half sacks ton area in terms of
players that had two or more sacks in a
game in a season Reggie White had a
season where he had eight Chris Dolman
had a season where he had seven games
with two or more sacks Bruce Smith had
seven Aaron Donald is now at seven but
19 and a half at that position is wild
he deserves praise from us because he's
incredible
Jacksonville at one point yesterday had
a fourth and forty six which is very
Jacksonville Baker staring at Hugh
Jackson's throat and Joe ku is just
Baker's the dude bro I freaking love him
he's the dude and I mean some of his
throws are unreal that's what I mean I
mean his throws are unreal there they
have quietly become one of my more fun
watches on film on a weekly basis left
go throw from Landry to brashaad
Perryman and say they faked the reverse
to Perryman then they toss it then a
reverse to Landry and then a double Pat
and I'm gonna raise the question which
LSU wide receiver has the better arm
right hotel or Landry because Landry not
only had zip on his it was a beautiful
arc and he threaded the needle he did it
wasn't like the guy was wide open he had
to make it like a legit throw and he did
he ripped it he threw a perfect spiral
it's you know and again going back to
great play calling and why it's like my
favorite one of my favorite offenses the
watch right now on film they ran that
play but they ran it with loyal injury
not thrown it there we go that's what I
was gonna say see that's how you tie
plays together so a defense goes oh we
saw this on film two weeks ago they're
gonna run that little run play they ran
with Landry for two touchdowns two weeks
ago and he pulls up and throws that's
what a great OC does those are the
little things I see week to week like
you know you've heard me talk about
their run game and how they tie the
play-action pass with it it's those
little things that I go for the
Cleveland Browns first of all whoever
your coaches make kitchen Jareau see III
think that is a definite like talking
point for sure kitchens is definitely
gonna be an OC somewhere next year in
the NFL it might as well be in Cleveland
because it seems like Baker Mayfield
also loves him
shoulder in the Browns are gonna be a
pain in the ass for the Ravens this week
that is gonna be I know I was only
surprised if the Ravens missed the
playoffs because Baker goes out there
and throw some piss missiles we talked
about matchup football and we talked
about how the Ravens matchup great with
the Chargers well I can sit here and
tell you that the Browns match up with
the Ravens and they could beat the
Ravens just pound them they could but I
you know I would I gotta see that the
Browns have not been poundabout
since Greg Williams is tucking over his
defensive coordinator that's one of the
areas he's fixed so I got to see it to
believe it all right so some Big Mo by
the way as you were talking I just got a
bleacher report alert right gets deny
Harbaugh interest Todd Bowles or head
coach there's no truth to the report of
our interest in Jim Harbaugh yeah okay
sure it's like they heard us talking
well yeah it's everywhere right now and
they're just trying to kind of calm that
down so we'll see where it goes all
right so the big betting things that I
saw this weekend there were some great
ones Tennessee Washington Tennessee is
up three Washington Josh Johnson pick
six with time expiring they go up nine
the line for some people was nine and a
half we got it at ten and because of the
Saints Vikings game they do not have to
kick the extra point so instead of
winning or pushing you bet on Tennessee
you lost in a heart-wrenching fashion
killer for the betters out there that
was I was thinking about the betters out
there don't worry you could talk like
Yuma Danielle yeah we're just gonna hear
you
number two the Patriots are up twenty
four to six with like six minutes left
Tom Brady sits down what happens
Josh Allen throws a 40 yard touchdown as
a Jones with one minute and three
seconds left and instead of covering
they get a loss the line was 13 they win
by 12 and Buffalo covers the bet Baylor
that was killer did you have the
Patriots of course I ad okay
are you kidding me how about this one
they had the Cowboys - oh god 27 to 13
and with just about a minute left Jameis
Winston finds Mike Evans for a touchdown
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
27 to 20 not a cover a push kick in the
balls what yeah I wish I wish they would
have got not to push so you better lost
more money that even better that would
have been great and then how about this
one wait wait before we move on just
from that for one second like just first
of all two things I mean again the
cowboy defense is amazing but a guy that
just never gets enough credit who's one
of the best of his position and football
Mike Evans like I hope everybody
appreciates what Mike Evans does on a
weekly basis that's no we can't we can't
yeah because they're always down 14 and
he's always catching a touchdown to make
it a little bit closer and he plays in
Tampa Bay and his quarterbacks of the
story for how unreliable I know but he
may it's not all [ __ ] yards with him
you know he makes a lot of big catches
when the games in the meaning you know
show don't I don't want you to do label
him like that we got it at seven and a
half but a lot of people got Cincinnati
plus nine the game is over Cleveland is
kicking the crap out of them and here
comes a punt block two touchdowns from
Jeff Driskel and they go for two and
Cincinnati gets down eight and they're
covering but oh no Cleveland Baker
Mayfield finds David and joka who goes
all the way down inside the 10
but after Baker Mayfield stares down
Hugh Jackson they decide we're not gonna
kick a field goal we're not gonna go for
a touchdown and Cincinnati covers for so
many people out there an amazing
comeback which just shows you betting
nine and a half or nine with a team like
the Browns it's just scary yes it is
you're right I'm betting scary all
together I don't know how everybody out
there
does it on a week I'm intense and
pulling my hair out with no money on
these games I don't know how everybody
else is doing it gambling makes these
games so much more fun but the big thing
on my mantle at home Sims I have four
tickets from betting that I made in
Atlantic City back in August right
number one I had the Eagles beating the
Falcons - two and a half that's a winner
it's a good ticket I'll cash it in
sometime this summer my second bets
Baltimore Ravens over eight and a half
wins for the season they just got their
ninth on Saturday winning ticket I'm
gonna cash that this offseason I have
two more tickets Sims yep
I have Buffalo under six wins how many
wins do they have right now what do they
at five five yeah I have Miami over
seven how many wins do they have right
now
Oh seven this Sunday Buffalo plays Miami
I am either going to get two winning
tickets and go four and oh and my
preseason bets or I'm gonna go oh four
two and split the year two into it
literally I made a bet in August and it
all comes down to this weekend
incredible Miami would like like I am
gonna be so invested in a game that
literally means nothing and that's why
gambling in the NFL is perfect yes
that's that's amazing wait so right so
wait you have dolphins winning seven
over seven right and Buffalo under six
oh wow that's amazing
yeah it's and I'm just sitting there
staring at these tickets going oh baby
come on
oh and that games in Buffalo - you're in
trouble so far deep trouble I just
didn't expect a buffalo to get the wins
over Detroit this year I didn't explain
them that's why like the sims and left
co-coach of the year like something we
got to give him a lot of credit for the
what he's done with that football team
this year ah killer all right and then
the other remaining sprinkles that I had
yeah
aaron rodgers needed to put on a display
to show every coaching candidate don't
worry about how i'm hard to deal with
don't worry about the situation here in
Green Bay because with no coaching staff
helping me I can show you without
McCarthy that I can hang up 442 yards
for total touchdowns and come back down
late and win a game by myself because of
Aaron frickin Rogers and I can do
whatever the hell I want yeah it was
amazing and I'm not gonna sit here and
tell you I was watching that game you
know with laser focus throughout the day
but all I know is in the fourth corner I
started to perk up because I went whoa
yeah they're down 35 to 20 and as you
know we talked about with him a lot and
I think we talked about this during our
podcast last week the Jets are the type
of team that I I thought Rodgers could
take over against right because they
have no edge speed no pass rushers to
where you know he could do what he did
which was dance around and make throws
and scramble and yeah he just reminded
us before the season's over like hey
yeah Patrick mahomes is really good but
don't forget about me everybody awesome
and also I'm super happy that my man Sam
darn old is finishing the season playing
well it's like phenomenal he really that
was a great game by him yesterday next
left go sprinkle as everyone's going to
Crown Baker Mayfield Rookie of the Year
the Rookie of the Year in the NFL is
sake won Berkeley as of today he has
eighteen hundred and eighty six total
yards in the history of the NFL he's
currently fourth for rookies and total
yards with 38 more yards on Sunday he
will move to number three surpassing
Billy Sims behind Olie Eric Dickerson
and Edgerrin James
both of those guys in most publications
won Offensive Rookie of the Year that
year however Dickerson did lose it to a
number of places to who Dan Marino who
led the Dolphins to a 12 and 4 record
and a Superbowl run so let me just say
this Baker Mayfield is not having the
same season as Dan freakin Marino a Quan
Barclay has a chance with 124 yards to
have 2000 all-purpose yards in the
season which no people predicted except
for Christmas thank you sir
Chris Simms said say Quan Barkley would
have 2000 total yards which is an absurd
prediction and if he gets it sake 1
should be Offensive Rookie of the Year
he did it the whole year without doubt
good Lefko I mean you're I'm glad you're
saying that one more time he's he's the
best running back in football nobody
does more with less and the thing I
always say is I just beat this into
people's brains remember this is the
same team that we complained that the
offensive line can't protect the
quarterback but nobody wants to use that
excuse to go say qualm Barclay is
running for 1,100 yards against behind
this crappy offensive line that's what I
don't get it so so one player and the
team gets the benefit of the offensive
line not being good and then the other
guy who's actually playing good nobody
talks about he's doing well with that
same offensive line you're saying is bad
for the other guy on the offense so that
that's where I look at it for him to be
averaging four point nine yards per
carry Wow
the same that is used to excuse Eli
exactly this is crazy that's one of the
greatest stats of the seasons the fact
that he's averaging the same as Ezekiel
Elliott and Todd Gurley a little more
than his echolalia
per carry and he has that old line hmm
another running back that was part of my
sprinkle I just want to say that Todd
Gurley is amazing but when I look up at
237 on championship fantasy football
Sunday
and that means a lot of people are
expecting him to play at 4 o'clock and
he's a surprise inactive is one of the
ultimate gut shots I've ever seen
yeah like amazing all year this is
completely related to fantasy wild wild
yeah that was that was wild but that was
the right play I'm glad they did that
there's not good at rest right exactly
no other thing I'll say is at one point
yesterday
Cody Kessler goes down and Blake bortles
comes into the game apparently it was a
coach's decision because Doug Marrone is
flip-flopping black to Blake and I want
to give a shout out to the guy that slid
into my DMS right after the game and
said hey mf'er bortles just got the win
he's clutch AF say his name you owe him
an apology when the Jacksonville Jaguars
went on a pick six and bortles throws
for less than 40 yards I want to give a
special shout-out to the bordel
supporters out there that still believe
I don't know where you guys are from I
don't know how you got to this place I
don't know who raised you but thank you
because your loyalty is unmatched and
I've never seen anything like it you're
a little crazy but man I appreciate your
love for the seventieth best quarterback
in the NFL what what a guy that guy
that's loaded my DMS what a guy what a
guy he was waiting as soon as it ended I
get the DM bortles is clutch it was like
you're out of your freakin mind that's
what everybody was thinking when they
were watching that one was man that
quarterback is clutch look at that yep
yeah I don't even know how to talk about
that subject it's funny it's funny is
I've had like people you know over the
last month just been like man you were
right about the bortles thing you really
stuck to your guns you were right you
know and I want to be like I mean of
course I was right I mean I don't know
what anybody was watching before that
just garbage time stats and that was
proven everybody are making everybody's
case but man that
like one ugly game I didn't waste too
much I didn't I didn't see I saw
literally 40 seconds of it but I bet 200
Bleacher bucks sounded like an idiot Oh
little news that just came out DJ
swearin sure was just cut I don't know
if you saw his postgame comments on
Saturday no what did he see after the
game he pretty much called out minovsky
and said why would you put us a
man-to-man when we are a defense that
loves to look at the quarterback and we
thrive in zone and you kept putting us a
man the man and he did that for like a
minute and 20 seconds and now he's cut
and he was by far their best safety this
season wow that's that's huge I mean he
was really one of the leaders of their
defense but he has spouted off a lot as
of late and it's obviously gone into the
meeting rooms and of course saying it
publicly that's just yeah he's not that
good to where he can call out coaches
like that he's a good player he's got
great attitude he's always on his game
as far as knowing it's kind of the
quarterback of that defense but he's not
talented enough to where he needs to be
calling out the organization he's not on
that level mmm
right before we went on I went on
Twitter and I said I'm coming in I'm the
only one there who what any questions
before we get to it so let's do three
quickly and we'll wrap up at around an
hour 15 all right David Green what would
be the over/under total on a Ravens
Bears Super Bowl what do you think - -
well he's saying over/under yeah like
how many points total if the Ravens
played the Bears in the Superbowl by the
way my AFC Championship prediction of
ravens Texans would be a very saucy
championship that would be that would be
a bloodbath I think like Ravens Bears
over/under would probably be like 42
points somewhere in there
right I mean something maybe yeah I
would say it gets to the 40s but not
much more than that
maybe 38 I don't think so but I would
say about 42 um you got a guess yeah I
think it might be like 38 yeah yeah it's
somewhere in that range
Douglas Cotchin if you guys could play
football with any player past or present
who would you play with ooh
any player past or present
I would pick Mike Alstott it is yeah
what is it like to hand off and just
watch him bludgeon Oh aye he was one of
the again and one of the more freaky
guys that was ever around his ability to
take on hits and like put his right
shoulder like all the way down to his
right ankle and like take people on that
way and then bounce off balance was
insane insane his leg power is insane he
was one of the greatest pranksters ever
he was you know really one of the first
hybrid like tailback fullback
combinations in the NFL where yeah he
could be a traditional fullback but when
we got late in the fourth quarter we
said okay you're back the tailback start
wearing people out
he was pretty awesome but I'd have to go
with like I actually think of guys like
glory I think of like personalities more
like Lawrence Taylor or Deion Sanders
like to be on teams with them and their
prime and to be able to see that and
their you know their attitude and flavor
that they bring to the the locker room
on a daily basis it would be someone
along those lines
last one here from Bayer rebels which i
think is a great question what's it like
as a player for your team to have
coaching rumors firing and/or hiring it
is you've talked before about brandon
marshall playing when you're up for a
contract i stress that that has yet what
is it like when you're coach though the
leader of your team is being rumored to
be on the house yeah it's it's not easy
you those are where you hear all the
cliches from players to just go like I
just got to worry about my job I got to
continue to work because you do you sit
there and you go just like anybody at
any job when you know the the head
people at your office are gonna be gone
or rumored to be on you go man is that
gonna be me to is the new head coach
gonna like me as a new GM gonna like me
so really as a player you just try to
like I said cliche it and block all the
noise out and go I'm gonna play my best
game this week and
to try to play the best ball I can to
where the next staff comes in and they
evaluate me hopefully they like me
because as you and I both know only the
superstars are gonna be guaranteed to be
back when there's a regime change like
that yeah the the guys that are being
paid the most and the three or four best
players yeah sure you're locked to be
there no matter who comes in but
everybody else is gonna be going on to
the offseason going I think I'm gonna be
here I hope I'm gonna be here but those
are the questions that are all in their
minds right now Wow as we're wrapping up
I get an alert that says Mariota can
miss week 17 showdown with Colts because
of that stinger and I'm just gonna put
my bias right out there good I want the
Colts as the six seed I want nothing I
do not want the Titans in the playoffs I
mean that was the annoying thing about
that game the other night I was going oh
my gosh I don't want either one of these
teams neither one of these teams have
anything elite on their football team at
any position or unit that's what I
looked at with those two teams I mean
when those quarterbacks can convert
third downs the way they were that just
tells you there's nothing elite on
either defense you know that's those III
won not Tennessee I'm rooting for the
Colts so hard this weekend I can tell
you that yeah Iowa because the Colts
have elite things on their team they
have an elite own line an elite
quarterback which allows them to play
with anybody
Tennessee yeah they could play with
anybody but they could also get blown
out by 25 in a playoff game and I don't
want to see that
agreed all right let's wrap it up there
Sims you're the man merry Christmas to
your family I hope that you guys have a
great time thanks man we are we're
looking for I got the wife she's cooking
pastas and she's so Italian over here
right now she's making seafood for us
for us a white people on Christmas I was
gonna say are you guys doing the Seven
Fishes we don't do seven but we got
three or four in the mix so yeah my
Sicilian wife's doing it Charlotte's
over here on the computer looking at her
animals
and Philips upstairs dressed like Cam
Newton already playing Madden so you
guys are gonna have your Italian
Christmas I am going to my girlfriend's
family's house come on
and I will be having a Nigerian
Christmas which is jollof rice which if
you don't know you need to know
incredible right and apparently they
this happened last year they're doing it
again they just dance so luckily I have
rhythm and I get down you do you do get
down so that's good I don't know about
you have rhythm but you get down so
that'll be good watch your mouth
for some homies federic is in what
Argentina Wow
that was messy yes shout out to fentruck
who was on a mountain bike ride today
which his vacations and my vacations are
very his are like work he's like gutten
doing Google Spreadsheets as he's
climbing up a mountain the only work I'm
doing to signing the hotel bill at the
end AFET he would say good evening and
the lef koe man says holla holla holla
we'll be back later this week with our
bet Sims is catching up happy holidays
happy holidays everybody
you
[Music]